[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le parlement
européen pour cette nouvelle saison
d'europe hebdo nous ouvrirons chaque
semaine ensemble les portes de l'europe
au programme de ce premier numéro
peut-on interdire le glyphosate
en tout cas en autriche c'est possible
et ce depuis juillet dernier c'est
devenu le premier pays l'union
européenne à interdire complètement
l'herbicide sur son territoire un état
peut-il interdire le glyphosate alors
que l'union européenne autorise comment
les consommateurs les citoyens européens
peuvent-ils se protégeait des pesticides
et bien nous ouvrirons le débat avec nos
invités en plateau mais avant retour sur
le sujet qui agite l'europe depuis plus
de trois ans le break site
et ce alors que la cour suprême
britannique vient de juger illégale la
décision de suspendre le parlement
décidé par boris johnson
un nouveau revers pour le premier
ministre britannique donc pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas tout suivi
aurélie d'afas a résumé pour vous les
derniers rebondissements de ce
feuilleton britannique aux européens
plus de trois ans après le vote des
britanniques après déjà deux reports de
la date du bric site
c'est désormais un second premier
ministre de mener le pays hors de
l'union européenne en juillet dernier
boris johnson succède à theresa may à la
tête du gouvernement britannique
et il hérite d'une situation bloquée si
theresa may avait réussi à négocier un
accord de sortie avec les 27
elle a échoué par trois fois à le faire
adopter devant son parlement
d'entrée de jeu boris johnson près par
les britanniques au no deal une sortie
sans accord au 31 octobre
il est bien sûr vital que nous nous
préparions à l'éventualité lointaine que
bruxelles refuse de poursuivre les
négociations et que nous soyons
contraints de ne conclure aucun accord
un mois plus tard afin d'avoir les
coudées franches
il tente de suspendre l'activité
parlementaire jusqu'au 14 octobre soit
15 jours avant la date du brds excite
indignation à la chambre et dans la rue
recours à la cour suprême et échec de la
manoeuvre du premier ministre
la cour bien de juger illégale cette
décision d skoazell cour a déjà conclu
que le conseil du premier ministre à sa
majesté était illégale nulle et sans
effet cela signifie que le décret auquel
il a donné lieu et est également
illégale nulle et sans effet et doit
être annulée
le parlement va siéger à nouveau boris
johnson devra composer avec le débat
parlementaire
alors qu'il tente en parallèle de
négocier un nouvel accord avec l'union
européenne
en cas d'impasse au 19 octobre ces
députés lui ont déjà imposé une loi anti
no deal ils seraient obligés de demander
aux européens un troisième report du
bric site
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau christian allard bonjour vous
êtes député européen depuis mai dernier
vous appartenait au parti
indépendantiste écossais et vous siégez
ici à bruxelles
dans le groupe les verts bon bienvenus
vous vous présentez souvent comme 100%
écossais 100% français je précise que
vous êtes né en bourgogne 100% européen
pour planter le décor autant dire que
vous étiez et vous êtes opposés aux
briques site
bien sûr bonjour et bienvenue je suis
opposé du président pour ces raisons là
parce que le 21e siècle aujourd'hui
quand les barrières tombent petit à
petit entre les pays entre nos cultures
entre nos citoyens le président se
retourner aux années de 1950
ou peut-être même avant donc cela ce ne
n'est pas du tout une idée du 21e siècle
ce n'est pas une idée du tout pour
l'europe et certainement pas pour les
cosses alors on l'a vu il ya des
rebondissements quotidiens toutes les
semaines voir tous les jours et hier
c'est la cour suprême britannique qui
invalidait la décision de boris johnson
de suspendre le parlement jusqu'à à la
mi octobre
cela change quoi est ce que cela veut
dire que on va être obligés de
renégocier un accord avant le 31 octobre
d'une certaine chose ça change beaucoup
et d'un autre côté ça ne change rien à
pourquoi parce que boris johnson
exactement de la même position que
theresa may c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas
l'accord du parlement britannique pour
pouvoir sortir de l'union européenne
ce d'accord il ne l'a pas je ne pense
pas qu'il l'aura il a certainement pas
le cas pour sortir de l'union européenne
le 31 octobre c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle il a voulu un petit peut être
contre la démocratie et empêché la
chambre d'écho main à
des communes a siégé pour pendant
quelques semaines et ça ça a été prouvé
pas la cour suprême que c'était illégal
et et j'en suis très content j'en suis
très content et matin maintenant je ne
sais pas si boris johnson sera le
prochain premier ministre le prochain le
premier ministre à la fin de cette
semaine
toutes les cartes sont rebattues a mon
avis oui je ne dis pas au niveau du
break zito niveau rop est grande
bretagne mais en grande bretagne oui
absolument
en grande bretagne ne savons pas qui
sera le premier ministre demain
est ce que le parlement va augmenter à
la pression sur boris johnson pour
négocier justement avec l'union
européenne
absolument puisque boris johnson n'a pas
négocié du tout avec l'union européenne
depuis et elle s'en défend je reviens il
a envoyé un papier qui s'appelle le nom
papier j'aimerais bien savoir ce que ce
qu'est un long papier un long papier
c'est il n'ya rien dessus ce qui a été
prouvé cette semaine c'est que et on
savait personne ne peut avoir confiance
en boris johnson boris johnson c'est
quelqu'un qui ne peut pas croire un mot
de ce qu'il va dire il ne sait pas du
tout ce qui va le faire demain la seule
chose qu'on sait c'est que boris johnson
veut rester premier ministre
à mon avis après la décision cette
semaine elle doit absolument
démissionner et on doit changer
le premier ministre en grande-bretagne
alors vous avez à la démission en début
de semaine michel barnier le négociateur
de l'union européenne sur le bric site
pour l'union européenne semblait
pessimiste quant à l'issue des
négociations
je vous propose de l'écouter en crainte
uk thinking sur la base de la position
britannique actuel il est difficile de
voir comment nous pouvons parvenir à une
solution juridiquement opérationnelle
qui répondent à tous les objectifs du
filet de sécurité
oui mais non cela dit nous restons
ouverts aux pourparlers au progrès et à
l'écouté des nouvelles idées du royaume
uni y compris en ce qui concerne les
relations futures jeunes chip christian
allard vous aussi vous partagez ce
pessimisme absolument je ne vois pas du
tout comment l'union européenne peut
répondre
un premier ministre comme je lui dis on
ne sait pas s'il sera toujours là en fin
de semaine ou un parlement qui n'est pas
d'accord donc nous à nous devons avoir
la place et le temps pour pouvoir
changer notre premier ministre
changer le parlement est peut-être avoir
un autre référendum c'est pour ça que je
demande au moins un an s'il n'est pas
deux ans pour être sûr 1re par jour pour
tout changer il faut absolument ne pas
revenir où nous étions nous sommes
depuis trois ans et demi ou vraiment ça
n'apporte aucune solution ne doit
trouver une solution et là il faut le
temps alors justement vous parlez de
changer de premier ministre est ce que
boris johnson il est discrédité aux yeux
des institutions à des dominions
européenne
vous pouvez pas être plus discrédité que
ça que votre cour suprême qui hésitent
vous a dit que vous avez menti à la
reine et que vous avez fait quelque
chose qui est complètement illégal
d'avoir fermé les portes d'un parlement
et surtout en grande-bretagne où le
régime c'est un régime démocratique
c'est un jeu régime de parlement de
parlement c'est le parlement qui a le
plus de pouvoir
alors vous parliez de la nécessité
d'avoir un an supplémentaire pour sortir
de ce marasme
à quoi servirait un troisième report un
délai supplémentaire on sait que dans
les négociations il ya la question
notamment du bac stop de la frontière
entre les deux irlande
moi j'étais une réunion ce matin ou le
sujet du bac stop on peut trouver toutes
les solutions qu'on veut si le premier
ministre et si le parlement britannique
n'est pas d'accord c'est pas la peine
que l'union européenne réfléchit souhait
c'est de travailler sur un programme ou
sur une solution que le premier ministre
le parlement n'est pas d'accord donc
nous devons solutionner ce problème en
grande-bretagne à londres à westminster
le 17 et le 18 octobre prochain se
tiendra un sommet européen capital
puisqu'il ya ici décidera aussi l'avenir
du royaume uni jusqu'à présent les 27
états membres ou plutôt affiché leur
unité sur la question du bric site
est-ce que vous pensez que cela va
continuer j'espère j'espère qu'ils
gardent leur unité c'est très important
et
je demande au nom de l'école selon la
grande bretagne de nous donner une
chance de prouver que nous pouvons
peut-être resté que toute la grande
bretagne reste dans l'union européenne
et si ce n'est pas possible au moins que
les causes restent dans l'union
européenne
merci christian l'art d'avoir répondu à
nos questions me doute que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
sur ce plateau alors qu'en france on
continue à tergiverser sur les zones
d'épandage
prenons maintenant la direction de
l'autriche premier pays de l'union
européenne à avoir complètement interdit
de glyphosate en juillet dernier si la
décision du parlement a les faveurs de
l'opinion publique autrichienne elle
reste menacé vous allez loire et en
attendant certains agriculteurs
continuent d'utiliser l'air be site
controversé ne compte pas s'en passer
c'est un reportage de fadeur et caire
[Musique]
une exploitation céréalière en
basse-autriche du blé de la betterave du
maïs et des pommes de terre sur ses 110
hectares de cultures lawrence mayer
emploi de glyphosate
pas question pour lui de s'en passer
j'utilise de litres de round up pour 10
hectares diluée dans 100 litres d'eau en
emploi pour environ 15 à 20 % de la
surface cultivée à cet été lors elle a
récolté du blé sur cette parcelle au
printemps il y plantera du maïs mais
entre deux cultures pour protéger le sol
de la pluie et lutter contre l'érosion
il a fait pousser du sahara d'un une
technique répandue en autriche où
l'agriculture se pratique souvent en
pente
regardez ces petites racines elles
stabilisent la terre et favorise la
présence de vers de terre qui
fertilisent le sol mais au milieu de ces
plantes poussent aussi des mauvaises
herbes
lawrence ne veut pas désherber avec une
machine désherber mécaniquement un pic
de retourner la terre sur deux ou trois
centimes et aidons d'annuler les
bénéfices qu'offrent cette technique
c'est pourquoi j'utilise du glyphosate
le feuillage reste au sol et les racines
restent intactes des arguments que les
ong connaissent bien le biologiste
hellmuth booster milite pour l'abandon
des pesticides
il scanne discernement ces arguments
sont utilisés depuis longtemps par
l'industrie pour défendre le glyphosate
and funding austria massif comme un as
et voiron faire un outil de protection
de la biodiversité où m des arguments
repris par les syndicats qui sont très
écoutés par les agriculteurs sur ce
qu'il convient de faire pour produire
c'est en place fonctionne et pour une
formation
or toutes les alternatives écologiques
sont absentes de ces argumentaires colle
au guichet alternatif et 1000 cas
d'interruption ce côté knicks vacances
pourtant les alternatives existent
l'autriche fait même figure de modèle un
quart de sa surface agricole est
cultivée en bio
sur les bords du lac de nos idoles c'est
le temps des vendanges
geeraert ribeiro moeurs viticulteurs
n'est pas conventionné en bio pour
autant il ne veut pas entendre parler de
glyphosate dans ses vignes vous voyez il
y à une abeille qui vient butiner du
pollen sur ce plan de rouquette en
fleurs quant à elle on peut en manger
mais d'amélie l'abeille ni moi ne
pourrions déguster ses feuilles
si on employait de l'herbicide en cette
fin cela fait des milliers d'années que
l'on cultive la vigne dans la région on
nous propose des pesticides depuis à
peine 50 ans on a réussi à s'en passer
avant ferme familiale et obtient et pour
notre famille
ça n'est pas une option en contrepartie
il y a un peu plus d'efforts à fournir
pour désherber mécaniquement mais nous
travaillons surtout avec des moutons
la démarche de gerhardt ribao moeurs a
le vent en poupe en autriche malgré tout
la décision du parlement autrichien
d'interdire le glyphosate en 2020 reste
fragile elle a été voté contre l'avis du
gouvernement conservateur
ce fut un long chemin mais pour la
première fois depuis des décennies nous
avons pu trouver une majorité au
parlement sans les voix du parti
conservateur
chaque espèce ne nous avons notifié la
commission européenne de cette décision
qui peut maintenant rendre son avis
gameiro mais je suis persuadé que
l'europe ne dira pas un état membre de
continuer à répandre du poison sur ses
chances
[Musique]
n'en déplaise à ce député rien n'est
moins sûr les défenseurs de l'herbicide
pourrait s'appuyer sur un avis de la
commission européenne pour faire capoter
l'interdiction alors l'autriche
va-t-elle réellement sortir du
glyphosate en 2020
réponse après les législatives
anticipées du 29 septembre
et pour prolonger le débat jacques je
croise invités jérémy de ces halles
bonjour vous êtes un nouveau député
européen la république en marche
rattaché donc ici au groupe we knew il y
à peu vous étiez encore à la tête des
jeunes agriculteurs et vous êtes éleveur
de vaches charolaises en saône et loire
d'un revenu également sur ce plateau
benoît biteau vous aussi vous avez été
élu député européen en mai dernier sur
la liste europe écologie les verts vous
si j'ai donc au groupe les verts et vous
partagez votre temps entre le parlement
et votre ferme biologique en
charente-maritime tout ça bienvenue
enfin gilles lebreton vous avez entamé
votre deuxième mandat ici au parlement
européen en tant que député du
rassemblement national vous siégez donc
au sein du groupe identité démocratie et
vous fait également partie de la
commission agriculteurs agriculture
bonjour à tous les trois jours
cette l'union européenne n'a pas réussi
à faire en novembre 2010 est à savoir
interdire le glyphosate l'autriche l'a
fait comment vous l'expliquez jérémy de
serre avant toute chose déjà si on prend
ce qui nous a été présenté dans le
reportage
li a aucun élément contradictoire à
l'interdiction du nifff aux at il ya
personne qui dit ben voilà on peut aussi
se passer progressivement de cette
molécule
donc là on parle vraiment d'interdiction
2020 sans forcément se poser toutes les
questions l'impact que cela peut avoir
est-ce qu'on ce qu'il faut à mon avis ne
pas négliger c'est l'évolution que
connaît le monde agricole européen et
français
parce qu on est aussi dans une émission
la française qu a connues ces dernières
années tous les agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui prêts à relever ce défi là
il y en a qui le font plus vite que
d'autres
benoît en est un exemple voilà et il y
en a d'autres qui sont prêts à le faire
il faut juste ne pas négliger tout ce
qui a déjà été fait et je pense que la
france et l'europe est plutôt à lens en
la matière et que ça ça doit être prise
en compte
on voit aussi dans le reportage de
fabien rey clair que l'interdiction en
autriche et bien elle est menacée
puisque ça dépend et ça a été un
contexte politique un petit peu
particulier
blé on sait qu'il ya des élections
législatives qui arrivent et la donne
pourrait changer à nouveau
messieurs le breton ah oui tout à fait
la donne peut changer mais ça peut
changer en autriche mais chez nous c'est
en train de changer aussi je crois qu'il
ne faut pas attaquer nos agriculteurs
qui sont très très inquiets de la
mauvaise image qu'ils ont à l'heure
actuelle dans l'opinion publique parce
que ils ont fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
utiliser de moins en moins de glyphosate
ils tiennent à le rappeler et et nous au
rassemblement national dans mon groupe
identité démocratie on a une position
très nuancée sur la question
c'est à dire que nous sommes favorables
à l'interdiction à terme du glyphosate
puisque c'est un produit cancérigène ça
a été reconnue par l'organisation
mondiale
nous nous sommes jeunes nous sommes
d'accord avec le délai de cinq ans qui
avait été donné par l'union européenne
pour en finir avec ce produit ça va
permettre aux agriculteurs de continuer
leurs efforts et de trouver les produits
ou des méthodes de substitution habito
c'est que on doit absolument aujourd'hui
placé l'agriculture dans un véritable
débat de société
l'erreur que nous pouvons faire et on le
fait trop souvent ici au parlement
européen c'est de ne placer des sujets
dans des logiques corporatistes et et ne
demander la dic aux agriculteurs pour
parler du glyphosate par exemple et et
dans le charger les consommateurs
pourquoi est ce que l'europe est
impliqué sur le sujet agricole c'est
parce que beaucoup d'argent public et
mobiliser pour accompagner l'agriculture
et donc aux motifs de la mobilisation de
cet argent public on doit nécessairement
replacer le débat agricole le sujet
agricole dans un débat de société parce
qu'on mobilise beaucoup d'argent public
et que l'agriculture le fondamental
c'est produire de la nourriture et
produire de la nourriture qui ne
contient pas des substances qui peuvent
mettre en danger la santé des
consommateurs mais aussi le climat mais
aussi les biodiversité mais aussi la
ressource en eau est donc dans cette
approche globale on doit se poser la
question du principe de précaution quand
on utilise du glyphosate que le principe
de précaution à ce moment là est ce que
ce n'est pas une interdiction dès demain
monsieur lebreton écouter non parce que
si on interdisait dès demain le
glyphosate ça mettra en péril beaucoup
d'exploitations agricoles donc il est
nécessaire de donner le temps aux
agriculteurs
de s'adapter à la nouvelle donne et puis
aussi de donner le temps à la recherche
scientifique de trouver d'autres
produits ça nécessite forcément un
accompagnement le passage au bio jérémy
decerle mais ça nécessite aussi plus de
moyens mais le passage au bio ou la
réduction ou finalement l'évolution des
pratiques sur une exploitation
celui qui passait au bio il le réfléchit
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain
et ça nécessite effectivement
l'accompagnement mais au niveau moyen
plus ça a été dit je pense qu'au tour la
table on essaye d'être le plus
rationnelle possible
enfin tout le monde s'exprime là dessus
il ya quand même derrière aussi des
agriculteurs il ya quand même des
réalités qui font que c'est pas non plus
bon pour tout le monde que demain matin
tous les agriculteurs français ou aux
repères changent leurs pratiques parce
que ils n'y arriveront pas tous et on
continuera de manger quand même des
produits qui viennent d'ailleurs et qui
ne respectent pas les conditions vous
parler du malaise agricole a en france
des arrêtés municipaux anti pesticides
et le projet de rnt ces zones à de longs
traitements et bien il semble que ce
soit la goutte d'eau de trop pour les
agriculteurs ils ont manifesté leur
désarroi il ya deux jours en aliments ce
qu'ils ont appelé les feux de la colère
je vous propose d'écouter l'un d'entre
eux qu'un lobby je pense
écolo l'écolo mobo qui veut essayer de
faire à 150 mètres 10 m ou 5 mètres d
aider mme t par rapport à des riverains
et je veux dire ici dans la métropole
lilloise
il serait très très mal perçu parce que
moi par exemple sur mon exploitation
bah je perdrais pour cinq mètres je
parviens à peu près cinq lecteurs on le
voit un agriculteur qui en a marre
d'être stigmatisés à vous disais benoît
biteau il faut que tout le monde se
penche sur cette question à l'école
alors comment on fait déjà le fait que
des maires doivent
saisir un arrêté municipal pour essayer
de faire avancer ce débat sur les
pesticides illustre au moins une chose
c'est que ce gouvernement n'a pas pris à
bras le corps le sujet des pesticides et
ne l'a pas placé dans ce débat de
socialistes roissy qu'on n'attend plus
que cela vienne de l'état où l'union
européenne si l'état avait fait son
travail
les maires des communes ne serait pas
obligé sous la pression de leurs de
leurs administrés de prendre ce genre
d'arrêté préfectoral municipal pardon
donc ça c'est une première illustration
après moi je s'en vouloir mais je trouve
le propos de ceux de cet agriculteur un
peu méprisant à l'égard de ceux qui
n'utilise pas de pesticides et aidants
et dans le dans la même veine les propos
du ministre de la culture qui dit que si
on ne traite plus on a affaire à des
friches
on a affaire à la disparition d'activité
agricole ça veut dire que des paysans
qui comme moi n'utilise plus de
pesticides depuis 13 ans je touche du
bois j'ai pas fait un seul traitement
depuis 13 ans sur ma ferme et pourtant
je suis en agriculture de conservation
des sols comme le roumain qu'on
l'autrichien qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
dans le sujet donc c'est bien la preuve
qu'on peut faire de l'agriculture de
conservation des sols sans forcément
avoir recours au glyphosate
donc je trouve ça méprisant à l'égard de
ceux qui font la démonstration justement
qu'on peut parfaitement produire en
agriculture sans avoir recours aux
pesticides mais est ce qu'on peut se
passer de pesticides pour toutes les
cultures qu'on fasse pousser des fraises
en espagne où que l'on soit viticulteurs
en grèce où que l'on fasse pousser des
céréales aux pays bas est ce que en fait
il faut la même réponse pour tous vient
mais de serre je pense encore une fois
qu'il faut pas non plus exagérer le
débat
si vous voulez sur cette question là moi
il ya quelque chose qui m'a fortement
agacé le vendredi soir où est sorti
l'arrêté municipal du maire de dangbo
est né à la question française et je
reviens quand même la question france
est ce que c'est ça ça prend tout son
sens aussi c'est yann arthus bertrand
qui est venu sur les plateaux télé
expliqué à quelle distance fallait
traiter
j'en remets pas en cause ses talents de
photographe il prend des très jolies
photos
par contre un peu plus de doutes sur ses
qualités scientifiques et quand on a une
agence qui s'appelle landes c'est ce don
ton tu peux quand même pas non plus
voilà regretter qu'elle existe parce
qu'elle est annoncée ni terre française
voilà voilà qui dit qui donne quelques
directives à suivre et bien on peut
aussi de temps en temps faire confiance
à la science
et je rejoins juste deux mots je rejoins
ce que dit benoît oui on peut changer
mais ça se fera pas du jour au lendemain
et les maires en prenant des arrêtés
malgré tout fige des zones du jour au
lendemain je suis d'accord avec ça je
pense que les arrêtés municipaux ne sont
pas une bonne réponse au problème
je voudrais revenir un petit peu à
l'europe au début de l'année 2009 une
commission du parlement européen rendait
ses conclusions
avec pour recommandation je cite une
refonte du système d'évaluation des
pesticides afin d'obtenir plus de
transparence d'indépendance agence
européenne et une stricte application du
principe de précaution on y revient cela
veut dire quoi monsieur lebreton qu'il
ya un problème dans l'évaluation la
dangerosité des pesticides
ça veut dire qu'à mon sens il ne faut
pas remettre en cause la dangerosité du
glyphosate
moi je pense qu'elle est malheureusement
acquise mais qu'il faut encourager la
recherche pour développer d'autres
d'autres types d'herbicides qui serait
moins nocifs pour la santé humaine
il faut encourager la recherche est ce
que tente de faire l'autriche de ce
point de vue est intéressant puisque
l'autriche est en avance sur le
développement d'autres méthodes car moi
je pense que tant qu'ils vont dire la
vérité la france a pris un peu de retard
en ce domaine mais on est en train je
pense d'eux le de le rattraper
grâce aussi au vote du parlement
européen en 2017 qui a qui a contribué à
demander une évolution et donc il ne
faut pas s'affoler c'est pour ça que les
maires donnent pas la bonne solution
parce arrêté d'interdiction mais il faut
que nous réfléchissions ensemble et
rapidement voulu répondre à ses
blessures sur l'évaluation effectivement
il faut refondre complètement la méthode
d'évaluation des pesticides par les
agences sanitaires qu'elle soit
européenne ou nationale parce que elles
sont éculés obsolète depuis depuis
plusieurs décennies le glyphosate n'est
qu' un cas d'école pour la problématique
globale des pesticides
mais quand une agence sanitaire autorise
des
des molécules sur la base du dossier
déposé par la firme chimique qui veut le
faire homologuer quand elle n'intègre
pas laisser cocktail quand elle
n'intègre pas la possibilité de nuisance
des métabolites issus des molécules
elle-même quand elle n'évalue pas la
nocivité des pesticides sur le milieu
marin alors que toutes les eaux
finissent en mer
on voit bien qu'on a une difficulté
grave sur l'évaluation et sur les
alternatives
est-ce que les alternatives sont des
nouvelles molécules à imaginer où est-ce
qu'on doit pas significativement engagé
les crédits européens sur des
alternatives basées sur l'agronomie et
d'agro écologie qui nous éloigne
définitivement des molécules de synthèse
qui sont dangereuses et on revient sur
le principe de précaution vous parlez de
produire autrement jérémy de serre il
faut également nourrir toute l'europe
le maintien l'agriculture réside dans la
capacité que les consommateurs auront
attiré aussi les modèles vers le haut et
c'est aux consommateurs également de
d'exiger des changements d'accompagner
ces changements les ensemencements ce
qui a faim quand je dis qu'on est
irrationnel qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui effectivement qu'il ya un
problème avec les pesticides
effectivement qu'il faut à vous elle
pose de nouvelles molécules mais la rage
eu des pesticides je suis pour de
nouvelles alternatives qui permettent
il ya des dangers il ya des risques d un
différend comprenant les règles internes
hâtives et bien des zooms des nouvelles
pratiques qui permettent justement de se
passer provisoirement des pesticides et
qu'on puisse du coup nourrit d'imagés de
nouvelles molécules pourquoi provisoire
jean nouveau nom mais provisoirement
plus tôt fait de manière pas direct
c'est un regret cependant les sourires
ce que je veux dire dans l'irrationalité
kiki un peu ambiante
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe il
n'y a pas des morts en rempart 4
tous les matins ni chez les agriculteurs
ni chez les consommateurs à cause des
produits phytosanitaires
par contre tous les deux jours et un
agriculteur qui sut side voir tous les
jours voir tous les jours dans certaines
zones en plus ou dans certaines
productions
il ne sut sud suscite pas tous à cause
depuis fait d'être montré du doigt ou
d'être un peu catalogué comme des
pollueurs mais ça joue beaucoup et donc
c'est pour ça que le consommateur aussi
nous autres politiques et j'allais dire
l'ensemble aussi d organisation des
filières des organisations agricoles
nous devons trouver des solutions pour
accompagner aussi les agriculteurs dans
ce show sur ce sujet messieurs seront lé
mot de la fin mai avant de se quitter à
vous êtes à la jérémy de serre les
benoît biteau tous les deux nouveaux
députés européens monsieur breton c'est
votre deuxième mandat je suis en bien en
amont votre impression sur ses premiers
pas au parlement
benoît biteau c'est d'abord une très
très belle aventure je ne suis
absolument pas déçu
c'est conforme à ce que j'espérais c'est
même peut-être mieux que ce que
j'espérais et et surtout contrairement à
ce que certains ont l'habitude de dire
les gens qui dénigrent le champ
politique moi je pense qu'il ya des
vraies marges de manoeuvre pour les
députés qui font le travail et qui est
qui et qui s'attelle au dossier pour
débattre comme ici gérer mes deux salles
vos premiers pas ici au parlement ça se
passe bien je vais pas m'ennuyer non
plus
c'est la fin de cette émission vous
pouvez la voir on replay sur les sites
internet des chaînes parlementaires mais
aussi sur l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes merci aux xi merci
[Musique]